i noticed in the super bowl now i i've
noticed this for years
whatever network has the game
they get to pimp for the big show that
they think because this is the greatest
platform you could ever have like 113
million people watch so whatever show
that you want to promote for the next
season this is the place to do it so nbc
had the game this year so they promoted
their big new show which is called bel
air which is a reboot of the prince of
bel-air now i remember that show yeah i
was so proud it was it was this cute
little comedy now it's been rebooted no
laughs
it was not a comedy anymore now it's bel
air it's about gangs and guns and social
injustice and that sirius has a
heart attack
so
we noticed that i guess the other
network shows this is a big trend to
reboot your formerly you know
light-hearted shows as very serious ones
so here are the ones coming up for
example if you love different strokes
you'll like this dark reboot a tiny
man-child snatched from the only home he
ever knew by a strange wifeless white
millionaire
what does he want find out on strokes
[Applause]
uh shit's creek very funny but there's
nothing funny about ex-millionaires
running a motel in a town that wants
them dead on shits just got real
the big bang theory was hilarious but
asperger's syndrome is no joke when the
show comes back as i can't feel love
[Applause]
a free spirit redhead and a cuban band
leader played it for laughs in the 50s
now see the reboot ricardo's scenes from
a marriage
uh bravo takes its housewives franchise
in a shocking new direction on the real
housewives of the 101 freeway underpass
[Applause]
uh the beloved characters from finding
nemo are back in a dystopian battle for
survival on fish game
everybody loved the homespun humor of
andy griffith deputy barney fife howard
sprague floyd the barber gomer and
goober but now this town inhabited it
almost exclusively by single men gets a
second look in mayberry lgbt
i saw you do a spit
and in this sci-fi thriller aliens are
real and this one only comes alive with
an arm up its ass alf resurrection
you